ついに今朝
８月ずっと一緒に暮らしていた弟が
この家を旅立ちました
うぅっ(泣)
うっうっうっうっうーうー(泣)
そんな悲しくないけどね
そんな悲しくないけど
やっぱ寂しいっすね
ずっと一人暮らしに慣れてたから
一人暮らしがすごい好きだったんですけど
弟とね二人生活を一か月ちゃんとやってみて
なんか、喋れる人がいつもいるのっていいなと思いました
はじめしゃちょーです
ちょっと今日は悲しい気持ちで動画撮ります
僕、結構8月中あったので色んなYouTuberさんの動画見てたんですけど
マホティーヌと親分（HIKAKINさん）とダンテが
何もしてないのに
誰かが勝手にその人たちのアプリ作ってたんすよ
いいなーいいなー
勝手にアプリできるってすごいなんかこう
*ﾊﾟｼｯ*
イラッとするよね
上手く言えないんですけどなんかいいじゃないですか
僕もなんか自分...なんか...アプリ作って誰かー
勝手に誰か僕のアプリ作ってくれないかなと思ったら
ありました
for はじめしゃちょーってことは俺に対するクイズってことですよ
だからこれ、はじめしゃちょーに向けてのアプリなので僕はやるしかありませんので
今日はこの、どこの誰だかは知らないけど
勝手に無断で作った
クイズ for はじめしゃちょーアプリをやっていこうと思います
ダイレクトな広告だな
YouTube1 〃2  〃3,4,5,6,7,8とあります
これ順番にやっていけばいいのかな
１番
Q,はじめしゃちょーは何年生まれ？
もうこれはね多分皆さん知っていると思います
190..あ、違う、1993年だった
次いきましょう
これはねさすがに簡単だよ
Q,誕生日は？
僕はですねバレンタインデー生まれです
皆さん覚えといてくださいね
2月14
はい、チョロいチョロい
Q,血液型は？
やっぱ天才っぽいのでAB型なんすよね
これてかさ、自分のことだから全部分かってて当然なんですよね
,中高生の頃は生徒会で副会長になるなどし、学校では”グループ内の端っこにいるタイプだった”という
そうなんですよ
中学校の時、副生徒会..あ、時間がねーわ
待って、隙がないな
中学校の頃は副生徒会だったんんですけどなんかこうね
グループの中でも目立たないポジションにずっといたタイプです
,動画を撮るのは中学時代から好きだった
いや、オイラ中学時代携帯持ってないから
これは違います
,友達と遊び感覚で”ズボンを履いたままパンツを脱ぐ動画”などを撮影していた
やってましたね
はいはい、そうそうそう
これ合ってるんですよ
そうなんすよ
まあ、良くなかったです
決して上の方ではなかったんですけど、やめてからもう
もうこれですよ
Sランク
こうはもう本人だから当然だよ
2番やってみよ
学校名がっつり出てるじゃん
怖
静岡大学です、はい
え！？
あ、そっか、150点下がったんだった
詳しいなぁ
なんでこんな詳しいの？
あ、これ待っていつだったっけ
2011年...
多分合ってる
*33-4*
2012年だった
いやいや、俺覚えてますよ
これは12回でした
え？
え、3回だっけ？
自分でオイラ、9回再生したから
たしか12回です
これは間違ってますよ
Q,イタリアに行った時いくらぶん取られた？
いやなこと思い出させないでよー
34000円ですよ
オイラ、自分だからわかるけどさ
ハンドクリーム...
タッチしずらい質問だな
やめてよーこんなの俺
ねーやめてよ、ぶり返さないで
ねーどんだけぶり返すの
投入してません
冷や汗かく内容だったね
した気がする
えぇ！？
こんなの覚えてないよ
あったね
何人か来てた
30分..
叩き続けてはないですよ
叩き続けてはなかったんですけど
30分間家の前で待ってたので
叩き続けたのねぇ
いや叩き続けてはないよ
納得しちゃったよ
ちょいちょい間違えがあるんだよな
はい、その通りでございます
違う
そう、元気の元
元気でいてほしいから”元”らしいです
で、弟はたけるなんですけど
たけるは健康の健と書いて。
元と健みたいな
だけど名前を変えて”はじめ”たける”らしいです
結構、豆知識だね
Q,UUUM所属日は？
覚えてますよ、4月の1日です
エイプリルフールで嘘をついて世間を騒がせた覚えがある
なんか軽い僕の自己紹介動画みたいになってしまいましたが
よくできてる、本当に。
誰だ作った人
わからない、勝手に作ってるからひょっとしたら
UUUMに怒られるかもしれませんから
僕は知らないですよ
興味ある方はやってみたらいいと思います
俺は勧めれない
UUUMに怒られてもしらないから
じゃあな
SNSでみんなと共有してね
※動画の説明欄にURLがあります
日本語字幕作成：今日の一言
完